you
44 44 44 44 45 the world of images has
changed we are surrounded by them we
create them we use them to remember to
laugh at to show the world a smile a
friend we create frozen instances and
movement in everyday life and
particularly within the sciences images
have opened up new vistas new
possibilities and have changed our view
of ourselves and the world around us I
think that without x-rays medicine would
be crippled medicine would really not be
possible to to do at the level we do it
today diagnosis would be impossible in
many diseases and also treatments would
be impossible to me it feels like we
will be back in the in this of only days
of the 20th century and people were
still struggling with the primitive
means to discover the structure of
complicated macromolecules and organic
molecules
in the world of science the use of
images has paved the way for some of our
most remarkable discoveries imaging
refers to fields of science like x-ray
crystallography electron microscopy and
MRI here images are not only used to
share information among scientists
images also reveal fundamental
scientific truths
scientists are now looking into and
gradually understanding worlds far
beyond our sensory capacities we now
have the possibilities of looking into
the body or into the dances of life into
DNA and beyond
this development has been slow and
arduous with failures hope and success
paving the way let's start this brief
history where some of us end up
occasionally in the hospital the
discovery of the x-rays was a revolution
in medicine for the first time it was
possible to view tissue indirectly
without having to open the body and for
and in the beginning of course it was
used for for diagnosing fractures and
and for simple kinds of treatments but
it's actually quite soon was used for
imaging soft tissue like the lungs and
then the computer revolution has
increased the number of calculations
that we can do and increase the quality
of the images but the real revolution
was actually the computerized tomography
a very different technique but one that
provides a similar view of ourselves as
MRI magnetic resonance imaging or MRI is
a superior tool when it comes to to
discriminating soft tissue it requires
experience and it requires training to
look at these images and some people can
become extremely skilled it's it's like
an art when you can some people become
very good artists and they can see and
look at the images and find me new
changes that can actually change the
life of a patient
within months of the renkins discovery
of x-rays physicians were using them in
the clinic it took a few more years for
scientists to realize that x-rays could
also help basic research the x and x
rays refers to the mathematical term for
something unknown in the beginning of
the 20th century some guests that x-rays
were away with a wavelength shorter than
light the difficulty was to actually
prove this here's how it was done anyway
if that passes around or through an
object will Bend because it is deflected
by the object so when you shine a laser
beam through an ordinary stalking you
see the scatter diffraction pattern this
pattern is only seen if the width of the
slits or in this case the regular
pattern between the nylon threads is
close to the size of the wavelength
crystals have a regular lattice like
structure which is so small that it will
only create a diffraction pattern if you
should x-rays through it the first to
discover this was German scientist
Maxwell hour when he passed x-rays
through a crystal of ordinary table salt
he created a diffraction pattern this
proved x-rays are waves but it also
revealed information about the crystal
building on these results the
father-and-son team of william and
lawrence bragg used mathematical models
to work out how these patterns could
determine the structure of crystals
flinging open the door to
crystallography the early days of weeks
wave diffraction or x-ray
crystallography they were rather sort of
primitive approaches to have one would
interpret the diffraction pattern in
terms of structures but I think they
feel attracted a large number of
extremely brilliant mathematically
oriented scientists to refine and
further develop the techniques to go
from a diffraction pattern to a electron
density map or what was in the crystal
they were studying and from that into
the atomic positions in great detail
the big hurdle was how to crystallize
large and complex proteins allowing us
to determine the structure of the
building blocks of living organisms
including ourselves when it comes to
interpreting images from complex data
some people are more gifted than others
like dorothy hodgkin who determined the
structure of penicillin this knowledge
made it possible to produce penicillin
synthetically saving countless lives
there was a sense of deja vu a few years
later when the race was on to discover
the structure of DNA the molecule that
carries our genetic code although
researchers could see DNA's diffraction
pattern the structure was hiding
misinterpreted finally Watson and Crick
managed to see what others had missed
the contribution of imaging to science
and medicine has been tremendous within
medicine x-rays and CT scans and MRI are
used together to treat illness and in
science x-ray crystallography and NMR
both identify structures that show us
new worlds so where can we hope for a
new breakthrough well first of all I
think one should not denigrate in any
way the small steps of improvement but
one thing which is not far away actually
is an x-ray laser because what x-ray
diffraction methods today are very good
at is to take a sort of static picture
of a molecule but it will be very very
interesting also to follow a chemical
reaction going on in sort of real time
to follow how atoms move together and so
forth kind of a a choreography and the
atomic
sort of that is maybe not far away
it's easy to focus on the big steps of
science on the peaks in a vast landscape
to see the broad brush of history and
forget the thousands of little steps
without which scientific progress cannot
be made like molecules longing to attach
rather the way they embrace so must
patience technology the team all come
together with those wonderful qualities
most of us possess as children but that
some of us seem to forget creativity
curiosity and an open mind
you